ينضم الينا من تل ابيب مراس الجزيره الياس
كرام الياس كيف بررت اسرائيل سحب كتيبه
جديده من قطاع
غزه فدا هذا ياتي في اعقاب اعلان وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي يوف جرانت انتهاء
العمليات العسكريه الكبرى واعاده الانتشار
او اعاده التموضع للقوات العسكريه
الاسرائليه تحديدا في المناطق الشماليه لا
سما بعد انسحاب او سحب الفرقه 36
من المواقع التي عملت فيها في شمال ووسط
قطاع غزه وسحب اسرائيل لاعداد كبيره من
الجنود
الاسرائيليين من صفوف الاحتياط منذ مطلع
العام الجديد وتغيير نمط العمليات
العسكريه في المناطق الشماليه على وجه
الخصوص لان الجيش الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن
انتهاء العمليات العسكريه الكبرى
والانتقال الى المرحله الثالثه في اطار
هذه العمليه والمرحله الثالثه من العمليات
العسكريه تتمثل في عمليات محدوده زمنيا في
الزمان وفي المكان ومبنيه على معلومات
استخباراتيه وان كانت لا تختلف كثيرا في
ماهيتها بمعنى ان القوات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه التي ما زالت تعمل في المناطق
الشماليه ما زالت تحاول الوصول الى معاقل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه محاوله الوصول الى
مواقع ال الصواريخ او فوهات الصواريخ
والوصول ربما ايضا الى مستودعات الاسلحه
التي لم تصل اليها في اطار العمليات
العسكريه الكبرى التي التي انطلقت في
السابع من اكتوبر او التي جاءت ايضا بعد
ال 27 من اكتوبر الماضي عندما بدا الهجوم
العسكري الكبير البري من ناحيه اسرائيل
لكن من الواضح بان هذه العمليات اصبحت
الان
مبنيه على معلومات استخباراتيه محدده
وبالتالي نحن نرى في ايام تخف فيها حده
المواجهه وحده القتال تحديدا في المناطق
الشماليه في جباليا وفي المناطق الشرقيه
لمدينه غزه او ضواحيها الشماليه والجنوبيه
وتعود لتشتعل في ايام اخرى عندما تعود
القوات الاسرائيليه لتتوج وتشتبك من جديد
مع المقاومه الفلسطينيه لكن من الواضح
بانه في الاماكن التي تتركها القوات
الاسرائيليه وتخليها او تعيد الانتشار
فيها نلاحظ بان المقاومه الفلسطينيه تعود
لتنشط فيها بقوه والجيش الاسرائيلي حذر من
ذلك واشار في تقاريره الاخيره الى هذه
النقطه على وجه الخصوص كما طالب المستوى
السياسي معرفه من هي الجهه التي
ستتولى
مسؤوليه زمام الامور في قطاع غزه بعد
انتهاء هذه الحرب على اعتبار ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول انه في الاماكن التي
يتركها وينهي فيها العمليات العسكريه تعود
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ل تملاها وبقوه كبيره
شكرا لك الياس كرام مراس جزيره من تل ابيب